it's a bit like bonfire atmosphere here
I mean it's now the fourth weekend that
we spend together on this breaker issue
tiring it's tiresome but I mean we do
feel personally as well that here and
what is at stake and down so you sort of
feel a bit with them it's long days and
especially long nights but we're all
right we're inside there's coffee so
we'll manage as long as the meetings
take that is how long I'll be here I
hope we end before midnight but I don't
know
there is an impact economic impact on
Japan so there are much interest in this
issue but it's quite difficult to
understand over the European think this
complicated issues I personally believe
that they will find a sort of agreement
one of these famous European compromises
that nobody understands but in the end
there will be something everybody is
happy with but i am sure when i leave
brussels in two years time the Greek
crisis or the greek thing will still be
being discussed but this will probably
take all night before they reach some
kind of deal and then it will take
another week before a final deal will be
reached whatever deadlines this was
meant to be it's not and I think what
we're seeing here is credibility of
everybody on the table
have a problem and the problem is I'm
rather loud when I broadcast and we're
all quite close to each other and I can
see the other journalists or the reports
on either side of me thinking oh god I'm
standing next to quest